richtig junge genau das hab ich auch gar
dem wieder christa mann er hat einfach
meine gedanken gelesen skills ohne
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
zuschauer überrascht das ist ein format
in dem ich bisher auch beim tsv
spatzierer escape tv mir ein paar leute
aus suche mit dem ich mich vorher nicht
abgesprochen habe und die bisschen
überrascht und zu einer aufnahme einlade
und ich guck gerade mal ein bisschen was
an ihr
das sieht doch nicht schlecht aus hier
oben oder ts ist voll
alter schwede ist der voll wird sagen
wir checken mal die sind nein das
herausgeben müssen wir hin
wir checken diese beiden klassen zwei
leute und zwar oder oben ist doch wieder
in gang glück gehabt jetzt kannst du
doch dabei sein und wir starten jetzt
hallo hallo hallo hallo
wollt ihr vielleicht mit mir ne runde
muss spielen so leute da sind wir heute
wird man kein bett muss gespielt denn
das hat alles nicht so funktioniert
ich war besser kaputt und jetzt williams
immer noch mit den werten gästen
ja genau hallo
und jetzt bevor ich es vergesse welche
dieses video am 19.6 narben zählt dann
checkt unbedingt mal den obersten linke
der beschreibung aus das ist nämlich der
link zu einem live stream account of
which wie ich mache nämlich heute im
stream ab 20 uhr wird die online sein
also checkt das gerne mal ab wie gesagt
natürlich nur wenn es am abend das 19
weil morgen um 8 uhr ist wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr
ok jetzt zu euch wie heißt ihr erzeugen
stellt euch vor ich bin michael jetzt
ich heiße steht werfen
finde ich gut 500 selbst gutes spiel
man muss auch selbst noch mit dem klar
kommen einem videos vergleich mal
treffen
oh ja wir sollten auf jeden fall treffen
sonst passieren nämlich hier nein eher
als auch holla die waldfee etwas nein
box sich gegenseitig oder ja da kommt so
ein derber clean up time sehr schön
wunderbar eigentlich müsste mission
endet runtermachen okay im hotspot
treffen schon tot sei nicht okay vom ist
aber so machen dass ich die runde
einfach weiter spiele und ihr erzählt
einfach was okay wir sind sehr guter
erzähler lich war ihr übernehmt den
laden einfach oder ich interview
interview klingt gut
okay gut vorgestellt habt ihr euch bzw
michelle du hast dich vorgestellt der
andere
stell dir vor also ich heiße ingame
gehen wir nach sieben partien gelang
sehr wichtig er nennt sich konrad
adenauer auf meinem test geiler typ auf
jeden fall
und wie nennt man nicht in der echten
welt das ist geheim
es bleibt sein okay okay er macht er
machen was draus alles klar
ein richtiger goma hd jetzt hole ich
bitte euch der holt mich doch jetzt
nicht der fall
hallo nähe der staumauer jo ok also ich
nahm bleibt geheim
echter name bleibt geheim kann ich
nachvollziehen oder auch nicht aber wir
spielen auf jeden fall ja mal weiter es
gibt noch zehn spieler reicht es für
level eines recht nicht von apple
ich kann mir diesen spektren das bevor
ich jetzt wieder eine kommentaren
gedisst werde mache erstmal besagt dass
eisen schwert ja wie alt seid ihr denn
verratet ihr das oder ist das geheimnis
lies wollte er wollte irgend jemanden
grüßen es können ja auch machen gern
hier als ich grüße experte nun klein tim
dunn grüße ich noch judith und das war's
eigentlich nur okay und du konrad
adenauer blog x3 und petit und fleckchen
und unflexibel flex und ließ sich auch
von ganzen herzen aber ohne spaß mit ihr
die gegner dieser maps gefühl die
verstecken sich aber sagt spielte
eigentlich öfter sg oder nicht so nicht
aufkomme
teilweise ja ein highflyer erwischt
acht leute verstecken
locker ist es irgendwie sechser team
einige sagst du ja ist das aber eine
erfahrung die mich hier ja ich hab level
hat aber keine pfeile
also ich glaube ich entscheide man
einfach ganz ehrlich da wir machen es
einfach so ist heute ein bisschen
unkonventionell runde noch ein
erfahrungs kugel otterfing die liegen
herum wie sand auf rettung
komisch ich sehe wirklich niemanden da
stecken schaffen seines schaffens bitte
was sie verstecken sich einfach eine
wirkliche sie verstecken sich gar nichts
wo sind die eigentlich wo sind die
eigentlich aber sag mal ich habe ja
meine these michael und zwar dass alle
leute die so sagen aus baden württemberg
kommen ist sonne
ja er wird darum ist auch einer erstens
nämlich jetzt bei vielen ist mir das
aufgefallen bei letzte bei stiggy bei
allen die ihn gerade wenig los ist
angefressen
der fall ärgert kann verbrannt hallo als
erwartet ob mit den lecks wird aber gut
gebuchte von mir der uci den hole ich
mir mal auf das anders
ok hab ich schon mal holt jetzt kommt
sie wieder auf mich ich nutze
gelegenheit um mal kurz wissen zu finden
ja das hat das heute laufen
ok es auch dann sehr schön und er hatte
viele vielleicht liefert ein nice einen
einzigen fall aber meine oma hat immer
gesagt was hat man was könnte meine oma
gesagt habe was mit pfeilen zu tun hat
sagt irgendwas sagt etwas sinnloses
meine oma immer sinnlos paket ein fall
ist deshalb kein fall richtig junge
genau das habe ich auch dem gedacht wer
ist der mann
wer ist der mann rtf meine gedanken
gelesen ja die konrad ist echter bist
der konrad adenauer alter konrad
adenauer mts und hingeben mädchens
kinder
es ist aber nun mal nicht so das ist nur
eine verlorene wette
aber man kann auch mit mädchens kinder
firma kd am 3
holger lala das ist irgendwie scheiße
hier wo wie viele laufen hinterher 2 und
wie dirk und ich gehe jetzt drauf leute
das war's von heute aber ohne witz wir
einfach auf den anderen wartet disney
kleines wesen kommando an
mai ist ja wie alt ich bin gut läuft bei
mir warum
ach ja hier warte ja okay natürlich auch
alte es regel zur umrüstung muss immer
der chain herangezogen irgendwie ist
diese folge ganz anders als alle andern
folgen die wsg war es geht sterben die
leute normalerweise lesen die leute auch
nicht meine gedanken eher verwirrt
normalerweise spricht mit bundeskanzler
normalerweise nicht
aber ich bin zu meiner schande muss ich
gestehen dass das jetzt nicht klar sagen
könnte ob konrad adenauer bundeskanzler
der bundespräsident war ja erst
verbunden ist einer von deutschlands
erster bundeskanzler von deutschland pro
jahr leute ich hoffe das sieht niemand
der mich kennt stande
konrad ich erster bundeskanzler von
kleinen job gemacht hatte
damit ist lernt dann ist der lerneffekt
für euch nämlich besser wenn ich mich
vorstelle so wir sind in das match haben
ein entspanntes reisen schwert was an
sich nicht schlecht ist und nur noch
einen gegner der wüste ist ihr schwert
holen frd lava turn up all das alter
genau darauf habe ich spekuliert dass
ich schießen kann
ich hoffe ich habe euch nicht so sehr
überlagerten dieser sonder wollt ihr
noch abschließend gemüse bestellen oder
so oder sonst irgendwas irgendwelche
abschließende worte ich überlasse euch
mal das letzte wort okay ich sage schon
mal schauen ob das letzte wort weil
schöne runde und na ja auch schon das
was mit dem video like a bird